salut les draft addict ah bah tiens
encore un arrière qui joue à kentucky
n'a quasiment un par draft et sont
souvent sous-évalués ses joueurs est ce
le cas pour tahiti washington dont on va
parler dans ce podcast son portrait du
futur drafté en 30 minutes chrono
[Musique]
tu
pour le portrait de titi voici donc mes
mes gros minet hector le bouledogue
évidemment comme ça c'est fait hugues
manu ben quand allez vous salue
je fais là ma vie
ça va très très bien effectivement vous
connaissez le principe pour ceux qui
écoutent partie 1 carte d'identité du
joueur pour poser les bases partie 2 on
se projette un peu plus dans l'avenir
dans la dans la projection justement est
ce qu'il sera dans une deux trois quatre
cinq années même plus on commence par
son histoire avec toi ben qui est taillé
washington j'ignore pourquoi cette île
comme ça qu'elle et sa famille tout
viatique
mais a fini en arizona le 15 décembre
lequel pardon le 15 novembre 2001 taito
washington a donc enfin parce je suis un
peu plus vieux il est le fils de tyrone
washington seniors et felicia caldwell
des paroles aux propos desquelles
beaucoup de l'information disponible ce
qui est généralement une bonne chose
quand on parle d'un jeune basketteur
maintenant je tout le monde se demande
c'est quoi sinon la taille taille
pourquoi ils s'appellent taille j'ai ma
réponse pour vous ah le vrai nom de
tahiti washington s'est taillé ron
washington junior son père s'appelle se
faire surnommer taille donc lui le nom
au départ qu'on voulait lui donner c'est
ty g et ne veulent pas se faire appeler
tidji donc son père a décidé de
l'appeler taille et ça lui à celle lui a
plu donc
taillé washington est allé à l'école ou
au high school ios à l'école saison
charest depuis aux eyzies comme passe
preuve je me suis intéressé à son un peu
ce matin savoir qu'est ce que c'est
exactement et zicom passe plat parce
qu'on entend dans un peu parlé sur le
circuit bercy aux états unis mais pas
beaucoup
exact à washington dans le fond c'est
une une école qui est basée à finat à
phoenix où est emprisonné à fiambala
pardon et ce n'est pas seulement une
école de sport spécialement une vraie
plus cool je passe une petite boule pour
les ors aussi plus près school
académique pour les jeunes avec beaucoup
de talents qui visent les autres
universités c'est un milieu qui me
ressemble ma foi très sain pour faire
évoluer un jeune athlète de très haut
niveau et tata washington a fait un
prophète tout le circuit
de pau fait tout le circuit high school
et élite mais il a fait le job en
braille classique donc ce qui est quand
même habitué à jouer à un très haut
niveau c'est un jeune garçon qui est
très
très très
discret mais c'est
je crois qu'il y en ait un intense
compétiteurs qui se cache là dessous
parce que vous savez cette année il a
battu le record de passes décisives dans
un match de john wall a kentucky qui je
crois est l 16 et qui a eu les battues
avec 17 passes décisives est ici fait
dire par ses coéquipiers au quatrième
quart et idate a besoin d'une passe pour
battre john whiting avoir ton nom dans
le livre des records des kentucky c'est
exactement ce qu'il a fait au
moment-même donc d'art le moyeu ya un
petit un petit four compétitif qui se
cachent qu'on n'a peut-être pas vu
encore à kentucky il ya des raisons à ça
c'était un comité très très tardifs à
kentucky je suis tout d'abord commis à
accueil tonnes et il a des commis
lorsque craig le coche de coûts et un
mec de matha inexplicablement
comparer son équipe une plantation
d'esclaves
donc j'ai décidé d'aller se faire voir
ailleurs un ton qui est allé à kentucky
a placé il arrive vite arrivé très tôt
évidemment il y avait des premiers ce
qui avait été fait à sa vie wheeler le
meneur de kentucky qui visiblement que
visiblement moins de potentiel dont tata
washington joue beaucoup offre d'abord
cette année mais tous les flashs qu'on a
vu on board laisse croire qu'il s'agit
d'un joueur quand même d'exception n'en
disons pas trop gardé en moi
merci pour la présentation et donc c'est
intéressant de savoir que cit ait un
fils il s'appellera donc taillé taille
probablement si on garde la même logique
hughes c'est à toi de nous parler du
corps du monsieur tahiti washington
qu'elle physique at-il à quoi
ressemble-t-il sur un terrain et en
dehors
moi j'écoute très bien même parler comme
ça pendant longtemps quelle formidable
ou raccord tu me régale à 28 me régale
talent et ice est un c'est un gars du
coup à m 91 assez assez développé déjà
en termes de poids il fait 91 kg à peu
près par contre une très très belle
envergure de m 08 donc ses 6 pieds 9 si
je suis dans le système système
américain ou canadien je vais pas faire
honte ndlr venant du côté d'eupen ce
soir
c'est un joueur qui alors physiquement
ressemble beaucoup à charles et
soignante si vous connaissez pas
l'humoriste française alesi la signa un
souci c'est assez particulier
pour le côté athlétique on a un premier
pas intéressant millet pas élite et dit
à mes yeux c'est un joueur qui est assez
puissant qu'il ya beaucoup côté chanson
physique jusqu'à présent pour dominer
les extérieurs et c'était ce qu'on
voyait au parcours parcours inférieure
cette année au niveau une ciel il prends
moi le dessus dans son physique niveau
du contact daniel a fait un premier
match contre le bouledogue vocalises de
duke il a complètement écrasé saluer
drôle c'est un joueur qui est pas le
menu vertical de très haute qualité sont
comportés extérieur explique qu'on a pu
avoir ces dernières années même danse
pour sa cuvée draft quand on parlera un
jour d'être édité ellison par exemple
après au delà de ça st un gars qui a des
grosses difficultés
à travers les écrans qui se fait
beaucoup prendre dans les écrans est ce
que c'est un défaut de latéralité je
pense je le vois souvent battu sur les
toits les premiers pas adverse et un
problème de rotation au niveau des
hanches au niveau de l'équilibrage du
corps je trouve qu'il a atteint à gainer
inséré intéressant notamment dans
l'élévation qui tient bien il ya une
petite petite peur d'aller au niveau du
panier alors que c'est un joueur qui
était assez physique jusqu'à présent
donc ça j'ai envie de savoir ce que
c'est plus physique est ce que cette
technique est ce que c'est plus mental
et est à suivre
je suis très surpris de savoir qui fait
un taille poids il fait il fait qu'il
fait fin visuellement je trouve mais ça
veut dire qu'il est qu'il est dense
aussi
manu pourquoi parle-t-on de lui pourquoi
parle-t-on de tahiti washington comme
d'un prospect
qui devrait être drafté théoriquement en
juin trois choses parce que c'est un
meneur qui est capable de quasiment tout
faire moi j'aime beaucoup sa capacité ou
au tir notamment capable de poules hub
de partout sur le cas ça moi je trouve
ça super intéressant pour un pour un
meneur et aussi pour ça sa vision de jeu
belle on a parlé de son record à 7
passes décisives c'est il est très très
bon là dedans même si pour être encore
meilleur je pense dans nba avec le
spacing avec des joueurs un peu plus
développée notamment sur sur le pick and
roll oui c'est très très très faible sur
ce qui est proposé avec angie
pour moi c'est vraiment ces deux choses
à sa vision de jeu de passe et sa
capacité à attirer de toutes les façons
et un peu partout sauf prenne fin près
du cercueil dit pas il va pas trop trop
trop souvent c'est peut-être la chose à
à travailler pour le futur effectivement
il ne va pas au cercle c'est la grosse
critique qui est fait à tahiti
washington cette saison
donc on va commencer les les questions
par là si vous voulez bien effectivement
son sont aux deux lancers francs est
inférieur à 15 est traître très très
rare pour les pour les prospects nba du
prévu dans le top 20 on va dire
pourquoi il n'y va pas d'abord pourquoi
il n'y va pas ben est ce que c'est un
problème est ce que c'est un problème
qu'il n'y aille pas et si oui pourquoi
il n'y va pas est ce que c'est
il manque du dribble et ce qui manque de
la vitesse ce qui manque de la volonté
est ce que c'est le système de cali
paris
c'est un problème oui et non ça va être
un problème dépendant de la simulation
si on lui demande d'être un joueur comme
il est accueilli un peu love bâle un peu
deuxième créateur en attaque à froid ça
va être un immense croix bleue un petit
plus pour attaquer de serre si on lui
donne wallon moi j'ai vu les capacités
intéressant pour pékin drôle avec un bon
partenaire de pick and roll avec
justement comme disait manu des
shooteurs pour espacer moi je pense
qu'il va se rendre beaucoup plus souvent
au cercle qu'il le fait à kentucky
mail à savoir s'il ya une espèce
justement deux gènes dans l'espace
justement dans les petits espaces de de
problèmes physiques je pense pas que ce
soit ce type ce soit le premier site
beezik qu'elles soient pas ce qui est
quand même assez dur au contact mais je
crois qu'il ya définitivement beaucoup
de potentiel de développement à passer
dans des petits espaces un peu à la
région de wenzhou dans ces deux années
là rejoindre à ses besoins si vous vous
rappelez c'est un finisseur absolument
incroyable parce qu'il est fait petit il
est fait si il est fait très très faim
comme on dit en france et moi je crois
que c'est vraiment un de ses joueurs
typiques comme je disais sur twitter ce
matin si mike magee beaucoup de réponses
que john calipari cache un peu dans son
jeu moi je crois que si on donne le
ballon à tahiti washington qui on le
fait jouer un pick and roll dans une
attaque d'une vie je crois qu'il va se
rendre beaucoup plus chaud je crois que
hughes est pas d'accord
pas totalement en fait on a vu on a eu
droit de match ou servir wheeler était
blessé parce qu'ils ont des impacts
gigantesque et qu'il est tout petit mot
qui très souvent sont c'est une compil
perdreaux la vente sur internet c'est
pas bien le m'énerver intolérable et on
l'a vu balle en main on l'a vu à nice et
du pick and roll etc c'est un très très
bon passeur on va y revenir je pense un
très très bon passeur pour les rolmen
des passes au sol des bons espaces
formidable gestion du tempo incroyable
il a un flotteur il a une excellente
l'autorun l'excellent runner il y avait
pierre qui nous donnait une pierre qui
est le spécialiste est ici envergure qui
nous donne hélas les stones
je crois que l'un des meilleurs
pourcentages au fait le tour de toutes
les filles mais ça en devient ridicule
c'est que certaines fois il a dès les
yeux ouverts enfin iliad est un axe est
vraiment au panier il ya un défenseur
mais moins défenseur extérieur et prend
un flotteur à 1 contre 0,1 contre un mec
l'externe qu
est ce qu on dit y aura plus d espace où
y est ce qu'il y aura plus au cercle je
suis pas sûr en fait ils aiment
tellement lui distance il en fait
tellement que ça me semble vraiment
problématique comme inspection
est ce que yaman eu un problème
d'efficacité du coût potentiel à ne pas
aller ni sur la ligne des lancers francs
ni auxerre qui va au serbe deux fois par
match en gros il a deux tentatives près
du cercle par match pile poil je crois
et il prend très peu de lancers francs
on l'a dit est ce que pour toi ça peut
ça peut poser un problème d'efficacité
est ce que il a existé des joueurs dans
ce moule là avec cette attitude là et
qui qui ont été meneur titulaire par la
suite en nba
là comme ça des exemples non après il va
très très peu au cercle mais quand il y
va il score quasiment à chaque fois il
est une super bonne réussite là aux
traits du cercle il a plu
j'ai plusieurs chine j'ai 62 % notamment
mais après ce que d'être femme c'était
les jeux pas en quoi sont beaucoup de la
transe ce soit un pay pal hors de france
où il ya un peu des fois des circuits
ceci où il fait des sous le panier mais
c'est de plus en plus rares
jusqu'à un certain point qu'il en faut
mais pas vraiment une question de
répétition une question du mieux de de
mémoire musculaire de de fin de
l'agression en entraînement
dans une équipe qui joue demain qui
veulent lui donner les clés je prêche
pour ma paroisse parce que je le veux à
new york mais new york disant on va le
faire attaquer le cercle jusqu'à pain
qui dessert à chaque fois c'est la
présence d'oscar çi winch plus gêné
aussi un peu parce qu'ils programment
beaucoup de place dans la peinture et il
part pas à plus de 2 cm du cercle ont
plus a toujours un assez fort l'îcone
très très souvent dans son panier y fait
des petits mi distance mais mais je
pense que ça s'est un peu loupé ses 40%
de cette sirène les distances qu'il
reprend d'efficacité de chez bouygues
donc ces deux tirs sur cinq à
mi-distance
millicom fortement présent sous le
panier je pense que ça peut aussi le
veut le dissuader d'aller au cercle et
du coup ils tentent des baux
coudronniere beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup
c'est fait quasiment que ça met du coup
dans sa situation moi ils me rappellent
eux quickly l'année dernière quand il
est au football
quasiment delà les mêmes system seller
sur sur sa où il joue à l'extérieur
beaucoup trois points et où il va au
cirque les îles fédéraux honneur que
claye faisait exactement la même chose
beaucoup de rohner aussi comme ça et
danton la vision du deux matches comme
ça moi j'ai l'impression de voir clichés
plus claire tout c'est vrai qu'on
reprochait beaucoup à côté avant sa
draft son
son fouillis trop raide c'était 1-1 d un
des points faibles sur le profil
statistique d'immanuel quickly c'était
le cas dans le fréquence assure mais
est-ce qu'il n'ya pas aussi un problème
2 - gauche parce que pierre donc on ne
voit pas une phobie notre infographie en
nous disant que tahiti washington par
exemple et j'avais l'impression visuelle
de sa qui prenaient peu tir de la main
gauche peu de lait yop de la main gauche
et quand ils y aller c'était vraiment
horrible à chaque fois et il nous sort
l'infographie un chercheur 5 et près de
la main gauche pour tailler taille et
seulement 10 % d'efficacité donc
finalement au niveau du scouting
répondre quand elle est orientée au
niveau de sa main gauche et qu'on me
donne une ligne de drive car ils n'y
arrivent pas et finir donc ça peut être
aussi un problème qu'il a eu que tu
disais dans le chat qu'on a entre nous
tyrese tu veux dire halliburton sur le
sur le côté un peu faim longiline va pas
au cercle
c'est ça le deal il est plus petit
il a un tout qui part de plus haut
ce qui est pas difficile et
ce côté voit qu'il va pas au panier qui
a un excellent gestionnaire de
l'entrevue en excellent passeur dans
l'antre de et moi je pensais que tu
ailles ou halliburton n'arriverait pas à
copier et je me suis fortement implanté
et du coup ça m'oblige à areva lui et
les prospects qui sont plus athlétiques
extremis hier bien le tempo comme tahiti
washington et donc c'est ma mon
garde-fous années chez tyrese
halliburton une des caractéristiques
c'était quand même aussi surtout dans sa
première année quand il avait moins de
responsabilités de d'être un défenseur
d'equipe extraordinaire avec un gros
cerveau on en est ou au niveau 2 de
tahiti washington là dessus je suis pas
fan de ce que je vois
surtout sur les sur du un contre un où
les pas il est pas top top et sous
beaucoup à voir je trouve surtout pas
les joueurs rapides donc j'ai du mal
transfert à voir ce qui pourrait donner
en nba en fait face à des joueurs qui
seront encore plus rapide et plus
développé et physiquement
par exemple on sait un croc exemple mais
à face à russell wesbrook je fais il se
fait dégommer je pense lui le renvoi au
vestiaire en un coup d épaule
c'était le cas aussi de halliburton et
ceci dit we do après il va développer un
programme de musculation il va
développer plusieurs choses avec un le
staff nba avec le sera mais un c'est
vrai moi j'ai du mal à avoir verte'
pourrait défendre qu'ils défendent
beaucoup au football il prend quasiment
enfants mangent déjà pas trop trop vu
prendre le meneur qui te faire le
porteur de ballon numéro 1 en attaque
donc ça peut aussi à m'inquiéter petit
peu
faudra savoir le cacher que ce soit pas
un point faible en fait comme beaucoup
d'autres meilleurs limiers ils le
mettent souvent sur des zodiac chinois
sur des passes que c'est l'amour est
toujours des 2/3 ouais ils défendent
très bien les ailiers reste bien
verticale alors là je sais pas si vous
avez la caméra mais moi je reste très
bien vertical j'essaie d'être dans les
habitue pas faire faux bond - cylindres
et il tient bien le contact là dessus
c'est vrai que c'est surprenant parce
que il prend pas en compte le dessus
physiquement attaque sur le contact il
le tient très bien défensivement par
contre dès que tu mets dans un de
l'écran il est fini à chaque fois que tu
joues sur un pick and roll ou à des
marqueurs du ballon un floppy sait très
bien que ben est ce que est ce qu il a
cette intelligence loin du ballon aussi
vous pouvez avoir un libertaire nous
conte les les de toute façon les meneurs
un peu longiligne comme ça qui sont pas
extraordinaires en un contre un montez
maurice etc ils ont tous intelligents
les chars si on n'est pas conclusif pour
l'instant sa dette parfois oui parfois
non
l'anticipation semble être l'un mais ce
qui est ça reflète quelque chose dans le
jeu de tête à washington que j'aime
beaucoup en fait c'est à dire qui fait
souvent la lecture de jeu évidente en
attaque comme en défense
il va comprendre un risque sur quelque
chose de complètement stupide qui je
crois qui le démarque d'un taris
halliburton
en terme de presque pas nécessairement
qui laurent meyer un mec il aura
différents c'est à dire que c'est pas
quelqu'un qui prend autant de risques
c'est quelqu'un qui est très
conservateur et
juste pour à chérir s'ouvre sur le
physique et le chemin la physicalité une
belle courbe de progression qui était
montré depuis leur s cool côté prise de
conscience de ces problèmes physiques
parce que c'était quelqu'un juste un
joie qu'ils étaient prêts pour ne pas de
faire de
2,2 pour ne pas dire deux choses
embarrassantes qui étaient en surpoids
ou un esprit et qui a vraiment beaucoup
travaillé sur son corps pour ce qui est
un peu plus petit aujourd'hui pour ce
qui me laisse croire qu'une courbe de
progression qui lui permettrait de
gagner quelques livres
oui il a vachement bien bosser parce que
ça se voie pas que c'est un ancien un
ancien gros souvent on en a non mais
c'est vrai non mais
c'est pas tout cela dit non mais moi je
le dis mais mais c'est pas péjoratif du
tout il y en a plein et si en plus des
des anciens gordini comme on dit ici
[Musique]
c'était au début de son exposé annonce
que l'année dernière
c'est ce
que vous voulez je dire vous allez v
tous l'air lampre vous avez tous l'air
de vouloir le faire jouer poste 1
il jouera post l'un pour vous c'est là
qu'il peut être le plus efficace je
trouve enfin ses lacs ses
caractéristiques de joueur de basket
sous le plus mise en avant de passe de
chou si tu le joues pas poster un super
beaucoup d'attrait de racheter le joie
moi je joue je je
je là je ne jouais pas serein pour sa
capacité à prendre toujours la décision
cinq ans picamoles dans tout les
damiers momie mouvement demain
limite ça passe à demain chaque fauteuil
que demain parce que demain on me le
fait trop bien et oui et c'est toujours
la passe simple aux joueurs qui
découvrent r moi j'aime beaucoup
beaucoup sacha joie de cet âge-là de
toujours prendre la décision simple la
décision payante c'est que
moi je trouve que vous êtes ambitieux il
a pas beaucoup de rêves poste 1 avant il
me semble pas quand il coule manu tu
n'iras si je me trompe mais ne sommes
pas qu'ils jouaient forcément poste 2 1
et là il a fait effectivement ces deux
matches sans ça vire wheeler mais la
plupart du temps il il attrape le ballon
il ya déjà un décalage voire il est en
mouvement
il sort d'un d'un écran du groupe
chinois pour recevoir la balle en tête
de raquette
c'est plus des situations comme ça qui
crée du coup déjà un avantage et moi ce
que j'avais noté ce que je voulais vous
demander c'est ce qui l'a le dribble
pour jouer postulants pour moi à l'heure
actuelle non ça si je peux aller là
dessus
je trouve qu'il est tellement bon pick
and roll un conte à plus grands
personnages vraiment il vraiment ils
passent vraiment très très bien aux
vicois il sera optimisée en tant que
porteur de balle pour le dribble ce qui
est surprenant encore une fois c'est que
il parvient dès demain il navigue bien
balle en main dans le petit périmètre
mais dès qu'il ya un joueur en face de
lui lors du contact encore une fois il
arrive plus à changer de direction et là
il est devient je prendrai un drive
uniforme en ligne droite et du coup ça
lui pose un vrai problème donc dès qu'il
a un peu d espace un vrai dribbles et
des cons à lui tombe dessus au contact 7
juin galère donc ouais on va l'optimiser
en poste eu un mais est-ce qu'on va le
faire jouer en poste l'un
disons dès l'année prochaine et si et si
oui qu'est-ce qu'il va falloir lui
apprendre pendant l'été messieurs
falloir lui apprendre à aller au cercle
il va lui a fallu avant lui apprendre à
négocier les écrans à défendre de pick
and roll à choisir c'est à choisir ses
batailles aussi va falloir le cacher un
petit peu l'on défend sa première fois
ce comté de de
commentry et surtout va falloir revoir
les attend il va falloir revoir ses
attentes je pense pas que se donnent les
clés à inquiéter washington la première
année il va se passer la même chose que
la première année de donner des clés à
je crois en son potentiel
physiquement je pense que tout le monde
le produit fini alors qu'elle quel
contexte ce serait idéal
ma nuque le faire sortir de bons déjà
nous pas le draft être trop poli trop
vite de responsabilité pour moi ça je
pense qu'ils attisent bien titulaire un
jour c'est déjà vraiment bien sûr comme
à ce pétrin de l'excellence 6e un
excellent meneur backup dans une équipe
tient un pivot offensif
pour moi il faut qu'ils aient un pivot
comme os quartier bois qui peut lui
poser un vrai écran qui peut rouler qui
peut tirer et qui va lui qui va obliger
les défenses à soi faire du drop soit le
à le laisser tirer en fait pour qu'ils
puissent développer son jeu à ce moment
là et rayonner à maxime j'ai une
suggestion pour ça c'est pas new york si
tu veux si tu veux qu'il réussisse pas
et qui gâche sa carrière oui c'est new
york eux-mêmes ainsi
ben voilà parce que moi j'allais dans
michelle robinson depuis quand il fait
du spéciaux
il est parti voilà j'ai dû me dire aux
besoins des dystrophies bon
mon chien avait volé ma botte
est ce que est ce que messieurs vous
l'avez entière 2 ou entière 3 je
rappelle le principe des tiers et al tir
un
qui va être en gros potentiel franchise
player
all-star franchise player tiers 2 qui va
être starter sur voir starter plus plus
et hyères iii qui va être starter - ou
très bon sixième endroit
matin la mer tout début de sa trop c'est
à dire que tu pense qu' il a peint
plafond seahawks à mais par contre si tu
le mets tout entière 3 ça veut dire
qu'il a un plancher assez haut je crois
que oui d'accord avec ça manu oui je
vous écoute attentivement je te demande
ton avis
moi pour l'instant je le mettrai donc
parce que j'aime la le potentiel à la
passer au tir et jeu notamment quand il
quand ils s'arrêtent en poule f mi
distance j'adore j'ai l'impression de
voir chris paul ça m'énerve c'est
étonnant mais pour l'instant il est 2
après ses pouvoirs comment commence a
dream et avec quel but que tu parlais du
pivot pour l'accompagner 6 juin mais
surtout quel type d'arrière avec lui
pour faire une traction est ce qu'on met
un arrière qui va du coup mettre de la
pression sur le cercle j'imagine puisque
c'est ce que tu lui reprochent
principalement à ses saucisses ne pas
rendre un peu le truc c'est que envie de
le mettre avec un arrière qui peut
agresser lessard qui peut scorer mais ce
concept store et donc c'était mais qui
défendent pas moi je vois jacques
lavigne par exemple chez moi et comme il
défend pas non plus les extérieurs des
washington est ce que tu peux avoir un
bac courte et fiable avec ce mec la
normale j'aimerais bien sûr de galles
amy williams d'achat
jimmy butler 10000 butler très bien vous
parlez ya mille ans par cerrone by jamie
m'avait calories en plus ça peut être un
profil un peu c'est idéal à terme mais
vraiment idéal passage en force est tous
un peu de chemin bas après miami
choisira sans doute pas dans le top 15
là où ça risque de partir quand même on
va le dire
pour les mauves grave pour l'instant le
classe
vous souvent top 10 est quasi
intégralement top 15 mais est-ce que
vous avez quelque chose à ajouter
quelque chose qu'on n'a pas dit sur
tahiti washington s'il vous plaît le
draft et pas trop pour son bien et c'est
l'essai laissez-lui jetta les mettez pas
trop de pression je aller très haut un
d'armes présentement je ne vais pas
aussi haut d'un moment grave c'est juste
un joueur que j'apprécie beaucoup
de s'exprimer mieux en nba qu'il l'a
fait à kentucky très bien s'est retenu
c'est lors de la question bonus tant
attendu évidemment tu l'as dit ben il
est né à phoenix notre ami tahiti
washington
tyrone washington
washington junien à phoenix de phoenix
n'est pas une ville de cinéma mais il ya
eu quand même de très bons films tournés
à phoenix alors je vous ai demandé de
choisir votre film préféré parmi ces
quatre psychose
le psychose d'hitchcock jerry maguire
avec l'excellent tom cruise a ri jaune à
junior des frères coen ou karaté kid
l'original évidemment pas le reboot
hugues je commence par toi ouais parce
que j'en ai vu quasi aucun super moi
j'étais trop posé dans le commentaire
c'était quoi de twilight parce que ça
fasse un phénix culture
cinématographique
on va dire une psychose parce que c'est
ce que je ressens quand je regarde
kentucky avec
très bonne réponse vous êtes très bonnes
réponses manu pas cinéphile non plus
donc fait dire le seul que je connais
karaté kid
karaté kid parce qu'ils en apprentissage
encore ok ok et comment il s'appelle le
mettre dans karate kid rappelle plus
monsieur miyagi monsieur miyagi c'est
donc john calipari
non c'est le staff de toronto qui va le
marquer
et ben moi ce n'est plus plus
la raison de joie
un peu raté des frères coen adorablement
ouais je confirme c'est bien j'ai oublié
de la liste little miss sunshine qui a
peut-être mis tout le monde d'accord je
sais pas si vous l'avez mais qui est un
très bon film aussi mais moi j'aurais
dit arizona junior comme toi ben
voilà arizona junior donc tahiti
washington junior pour ce podcast son
portrait vous l'avez maintenant à vous
de voir si vous le voulez dans votre
franchise nba ou pas nous on se retrouve
pour le prochain podcast pour parler
d'un autre arrière de cette draft qui
est un peu moins côté mais un peu plus
athlétique on vous laisse la surprise
ciao